Diffusion runs a large network at every
step.
Neighbouring steps compute almost the same
thing.
Caching stores one feature and reuses it
later, skipping the repeated work.
The question is how far one stored feature
can be pushed.
The cached feature is held while the true
feature moves.
Skip one step, and the error is small.
Skip many steps, and the stale feature
drifts away.
Errors accumulate, and quality degrades.
Reuse is cheap, but stale features become
wrong.
Most caching methods predict the future
feature from the past.
LearniBridge asks a different question.
What correction makes a cached computation
behave like the skipped full computation?
Cached computation plus a small correction
approximates the future one.
Stack layer inputs from many samples, one
column per sample.
The correction is the layer difference
between timesteps.
Model it as a matrix times those inputs.
The best matrix is E times the
pseudo-inverse of X.
Its singular values decay fast: energy
sits in a few directions.
The required correction is therefore low
rank.
Split one hundred prompts into disjoint
groups.
Fit the optimal correction per group.
Each has its own principal subspace.
Measure the angles between them.
They come out consistently small.
So a few calibration prompts can
generalize.
Look at the last Transformer block.
Keep the pretrained weights frozen.
Add a thin low-rank path, LoRA (low-rank
adaptation).
The cached input goes through this
augmented block.
It approximates the skipped full
computation.
Low rank follows from the analysis.
Calibration runs a few full trajectories.
Record the final-block input at a computed
step, and the true output at a skipped
one.
Train only the LoRA weights to connect the
two.
At inference, compute fully every N steps
and cache that input.
In between, skip the earlier blocks
entirely.
Only the final block, with its adapter,
runs.
Stale cache, structured correction, low
rank, few prompts, lightweight bridge.